[Music]
on this saturday night
bc calls for backup
[Music]
100 firefighters from mexico join the
fight in british columbia as relentless
flames force
thousands from their homes and push
emergency crews to the brink
plus the unprecedented wildfire season
raging across the country
and the continent minority report a new
opinion poll
finds the trudeau liberals lead appears
to be shrinking
ahead of a looming election call and the
growing
games as canadian olympians take on the
world in tokyo
some new sports are taking the games to
new heights
it's exciting it's it's fast it's fun
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
jeff semple good evening and thank you
for joining us
thousands of british columbians remain
out of their homes this weekend as fires
rage throughout the province's interior
and the forecast is not looking good as
far as fire conditions are concerned
with temperatures expected to climb into
the mid 30s through the end of next week
more than 3 300 firefighters are
battling the blazes
and today more help arrived all the way
from mexico
a crew of around 100 firefighters
touched down this afternoon in bc
heading to the wildfire front lines
after undergoing covid19 testing
there are now more than 260 wildfires
burning
in the province and around 39 of those
are a particular concern
considered highly visible or posing a
potential threat to public safety
all told fires have burned more than 376
000 hectares of land in bc so far this
season
that's more than the entire 2020 fire
season
when 347 000 hectares burned some of the
worst
wildfires can now be found in the
southeastern part of the province
including an out-of-control blaze
near the town of oliver and that's where
we find global's lauren pullen
right now lauren so how's the situation
looking from there
jeff it's been another exhausting day on
the fire line
here crews throwing everything they have
at it we have seen helicopters
and heard them going non-stop dropping
water load after water load
on this fire still though more people
were forced to flee their homes today we
are on the edge of that evacuation order
zone
near oliver bc right now where the inca
meep creek wildfire is now threatening
even more properties
the fire is still burning out of control
with flames now moving
north and we do know that again more
homes cabins and properties
along with places at a local ski resort
mount baldy have been evacuated this
afternoon
officials tell me this fire is growing
but because there is so much smoke
firefighters can't actually map up how
map out rather how much it has spread
there is some good news though in this
firefight in the south near soyuz
40 homeowners along with the spirit
ridge resort a cultural center and a
nearby winery have all been allowed back
after several days being out of their
homes no doubt breathing an incredible
sigh of relief still well over 850
property owners
are still forced out of their homes
right now
it was a traumatic situation for our
members that
that were pulled from their homes and
were able to grab just a few things they
needed
uh and we from our end it was it was a
scramble
at that time and a ton of people within
the the soyuz community just residents
stepped up found supplies came in to
assist
it's always great to see when people
just step up at a time like that and
support us and help out so
that was pretty amazing i was prepared
for it i mean we saw it coming with the
fire
slowly moving that way it was just a
matter of time
nothing we can do and lauren
fire crews there must be exhausted but
as we mentioned
more backup has just arrived so how are
they expected to help
jeff definitely uh welcoming all of the
back up they can
with open arms as the crews here really
have been working
non-stop and as you heard a little bit
earlier those
100 fire crews from mexico have now
landed
in bc to help with this firefight
alongside crews who are already here
from across canada
and they are heading to help the fight
here at the inca meep creek wildfire and
will actually be in action
starting tomorrow these highly trained
crews will be on hand for 30 days
working shoulder to shoulder with our
wild fire service crews
we can't thank these men and women
enough for heeding our call for support
we've been working under extreme
conditions with limited resources so
having extra bodies on the way is
extremely important
we're extremely grateful for the support
of outside agencies
and it is support that is greatly needed
right now
jeff there is no relief in sight in the
forecast we are expected to hover in the
mid 30s for the next
several days here so crews really do
need all the help they can get jeff
lauren pollen near oliver bc stay safe
thanks lauren
and bc is far from the only province in
the midst of a firefight wildfires are
now raging across the country fueled by
hot
dry conditions here are the hot spots
the situation is particularly bad in the
prairies
saskatchewan is battling more than 160
active fires
there's also a large cluster in
northwestern ontario at least 150
burning in that province today and there
are more than 130 wildfires raging
in manitoba in fact fire crews there are
so stretched that the military is now
responding to the situation in eastern
manitoba
86 soldiers are being deployed they will
be cleaning up hot spots and patrolling
the
area to help free up firefighters to
tackle more serious fires elsewhere in
the province
the military is expected to remain on
the ground in manitoba
until at least august the 10th and it's
a similar situation
south of the border with about 80
wildfires raging out of control across
the western united states
more than half a million hectares are
already burned with no relief in sight
as jennifer johnson reports firefighters
are struggling to contain the flames
while some have also been sidelined by
the pandemic
hair raising video as california
firefighters drive through burning
embers to get to homes threatened by the
tamarack fire
that blaze has crossed into nevada
homeowners have been told to get out
there's a mountain right behind my house
and the flames the fire was coming right
down
in many communities homes have become
piles of ash with winds picking up the
fire's path
has become harder to predict the extreme
fire behavior
meant that it was definitely going to be
a difficult time and in some cases a
real fire fight
scientists blame climate change for the
drought and excessive heat
creating a losing battle for
firefighters there's not a lot of
moisture
left in the ground and it leaves the
forest
any vegetation that's on the ground in a
state where a single spark could easily
set off an
inferno in oregon the nation's largest
bootleg fire caused by a lightning
strike
is still only half contained crews are
also battling a covet 19 outbreak
at least nine firefighters have tested
positive so far
on friday mandatory evacuations were
ordered in butte county california
as the dixie fire the state's largest
explodes eastward
hundreds of families left earlier in the
week and now anxiously wait to see if
there will be anything left
when they return we had to be evacuate
on monday
it was probably more than 20 miles away
and now it's within four miles of our
house
the smoke and haze from the fires are
making it very difficult to breathe for
millions across the country
especially in california definitely
pretty bad
you know i mean you got ash falling down
on your car
weekend forecasts for california and
nevada are calling for scattered
thunderstorms
but also the chance for lightning
raising fears that could spark
even more fires jennifer johnson global
news
washington and severe weather is also
hitting
india right now at least 125 people are
dead after heavy rain
triggered flooding and landslides
rescue teams are now scouring through
the debris looking for any survivors
this month india's west coast had been
hit with the heaviest rain
in four decades the severe weather has
cut off hundreds of villages
and there's concern that major rivers
may be on the brink of bursting their
banks
meanwhile china is bracing for a
powerful typhoon
just days after deadly flooding
devastated the central part of the
country
heavy rainfall is already hitting
coastal china flooding roads
typhoon infa is expected to make
landfall tomorrow
and not far behind that typhoon is
tropical storm
nepatak there's concern that it could
hit japan next week
potentially interrupting the olympic
games underway in tokyo
in australia frustrations are boiling
over over covet 19
restrictions wait what freedom
we want freedom thousands of people took
to the streets in sydney and other
cities to protest
lockdown measures police made several
arrests after crowds broke through
barriers and threw objects at officers
today new south wales broke another
daily record with 163
new infections half the country is now
in lockdown
just 15 percent of australia's
population is fully vaccinated
to hungary now where thousands joined a
pride march in budapest
to take a stand against their country's
new anti-lgbtq law
happy fried food our friends
hungarians marched through the capital
city protesting the policy
that limits teaching homosexuality and
transgender
issues in schools the country's
nationalist government claims the law
aims to protect children
and traditional christian values but the
european union is launching a
legal action against hungary arguing the
law is discriminatory and infringes on
the eu's values of tolerance
coming up ontario's top tourist
attractions are making a splash this
weekend
opening their doors for the first time
in months
plus the federal conservatives are
climbing in the polls ahead of a likely
election campaign but voters in western
canada could spoil the party
we'll explain next
welcome back toronto police clashed with
protesters this week as the city evicted
dozens of people living in homeless
camps that had been set up in local
parks
now some city councilors are questioning
the tactics and calling on the mayor to
change his approach
catherine ward has the details and a
warning that the images in this story
may be disturbing
the images from the clearing of homeless
encampments carried out this week at
toronto's downtown landport stadium park
are troubling we as a city are never
doing a good job
when our police force is
using coercive violence on citizens of
toronto
police say they were at the facility to
support city staff
and enforcement was their last resort
but some toronto city councilors say
they will not let the issue be forgotten
in an open letter sent to the mayor
friday they wrote we demand an
end to the violence and extremes show a
force adding the approach to encampments
does not effectively resolve the
challenge we face
as you are only moving people
experiencing homelessness from the parks
to laneways
under bridges or into another park the
mayor says the evictions were necessary
adding that the crowd that gathered in
support of people living there
was part of the problem last week there
were three
clearings of encampments two of them
were done without incident
why because there were no protesters
there at a certain point in time
after all the efforts we've made 20 000
visits to
convince people to come indoors that
there is a time when those encampments
have
to be cleared early in the pandemic many
people did not want to enter toronto's
shelter system
out of fear of catching coven 19 setting
up tents in parks throughout the city
adding to the complex and long-standing
issue of homelessness
in toronto we have decades in fact of
the provincial and federal government
not working with the city to create
affordable housing
we've begun to turn the corner on that
but
the roots of this are very much a system
that doesn't create
good affordable housing for people
outreach workers say they worry about
how
future evictions will be carried out but
will take their cue from those
who live there if the residents are
asking for more public people to
arrive and witness we will do what we
can to support if the residents are
asking
for less people to witness we will do
that but at the end of the day
we need to be centering the voices of
those who are most vulnerable and i
think the city's approach so far has not
done that and we're seeing that it's not
working
catherine ward global news toronto
a new opinion poll conducted exclusively
for global news
finds the federal liberals lead over the
conservatives has narrowed
the ipsos survey shows the liberals have
the support of 36 percent of decided
voters that's down
two points from june the conservatives
are up four points to 30 percent
while the ndp is unchanged at 20 percent
and the green party currently in the
midst of a bitter internal battle
has dropped four points and is now
sitting at just three percent nationally
but as our chief political correspondent
david aiken explains
the national numbers don't tell the full
story
all federal political leaders almost
never miss stampede week in calgary
but for conservative leader aaron
o'toole visits to alberta may become
more and more necessary to boost his
party's fortunes there
a new poll done by ipsos exclusively for
global news finds that just
36 percent of albertans would vote today
for o'toole's tories that's barely half
of the
69 percent of albertans that voted for
andrew shearer's tories
in the 2019 election meanwhile 31
percent would vote now for jugmeet
singh's ndp
versus 12 in 2019 justin trudeau's
liberals have the support of
24 of albertans now versus 14
in the last election clearly what's
happening here is that jason kenney's
struggles managing the pandemic
are starting to uh impact federal vote
intentions as well
and the ndp being in second place
suggests that uh rachel naughtley within
the province is having
a positive effect on the fortune of the
ndp
uh federally as well the trend in
alberta though is the same in manitoba
and saskatchewan
torrey's support is way down from the
2019 election
but in ontario and quebec ipsos found
voters in those provinces
would make the same choices now that
they made in 2019
consider seat rich ontario the liberals
have a commanding lead at
40 right now but that's pretty much what
they won in 2019
41 the conservatives have 32 percent
support in ontario right now versus
33 in 2019 the ndp though is moving up
polling at 20 now versus 17
in 2019. yeah there's not a lot of
movement in ontario it's pretty well
status quo from wherever we were in
2019.
now if you're justin trudeau trying to
figure out if you should have a summer
election
the liberals would almost certainly win
the most seats but the numbers are not
quite there for the liberals to bank on
winning
enough seats to form the majority
government that they want
jeff david aiken in ottawa thanks david
still ahead how the fight against covet
19 left behind one of canada's most
vulnerable communities
a fishy fixture of toronto tourism is
back in business
the city's popular ripley's aquarium
finally welcomed back
guests with masks today after shutting
its doors for eight months due to the
pandemic
the aquarium joins a slew of tourist
attractions that reopened across ontario
this weekend
including the nearby cn tower it comes
one week after the province entered step
three
of its pandemic reopening plan and the
covet 19 pandemic
uprooted life for many canadians but for
those living with intellectual
disabilities the last 18 months carried
extraordinary challenges and a higher
risk of infection
as jamie morocco explains the community
says it's been left
behind corey earl has an intellectual
disability and says the pandemic
stripped him of his routine his social
circle and his support
disabilities have been looked over
beyond this pandemic
we certainly have been left behind the
results of a large scale study out of
the uk last week show earl may be right
it found adults living with intellectual
disabilities face an
increased risk of hospitalization or
death due to kova 19.
three times that of the general
population people with down syndrome or
cerebral palsy were most in jeopardy
because of pre-existing conditions
including obesity diabetes epilepsy and
even poverty
laura lachance's 28 year old son kevin
has down syndrome
it was a challenge to get him to
increase his social distancing
and to be very careful about hand
sanitizing and to wear a mask in public
places
bashan says since she was able to care
for him at home
he wasn't isolated and was given an
education on vaccination
but across the country covet 19 shot
prioritization differs from province to
province
they may have been priorized but
absolutely people are going to need help
in getting access to it whether that's
online
whether that's physically getting there
etc
bioethicist carrie bowman says the
pandemic has highlighted the
marginalization of our community's most
vulnerable
and wants to see the government develop
systems
of access to support safety
as well as potentially vaccines people
were not treated
well at all uh in many many cases
during this pandemic and you know they
weren't prioritized for personal
protective equipment
their workers weren't like prioritized
there were all kinds of issues
for people with disabilities across the
country experts we spoke with say
unlike in the uk canada's not currently
tracking data when it comes to the
mortality rate of intellectually
disabled amid covet
however they have no reason to believe
the statistics would be any different
adding without further financial and
healthcare support
more people are at risk jamie morocco
global news toronto
up next the new sporting events making
waves at the summer olympics
welcome back when it comes to the summer
olympics we often think about the
traditional
big events like the 100 meter dash or
gymnastics
but that doesn't mean the canadian
athletes aren't open to learning new
tricks
as mike delay reports the tokyo olympics
are offering up some fresh fare
and hoping to take the games to new
heights
if you talk to most sport climbers the
olympics were the furthest thing from
their mind
when they took up the sport when it was
announced in 2016 that climbing would be
added for the tokyo games
canada's best briefly celebrated and
then chalked up and got to work
it's dynamic it's you know it's exciting
it's
it's fast it's it's fun the olympics has
a history of trying out new sports
some like ballooning and tug of war
didn't catch on
baseball and softball were dropped after
the 2008 games for being too
american but the international community
has caught up enough
that both sports are back in tokyo sadly
few fans will see either live and in
person
because of covet regulations but the
players say and cue the sports cliche
they're just happy to be here when we do
get to the games that i think will look
very different than they have in the
past but at the end of the day
it's about the product on the field and
the teams competing for a medal for
their country
fans no fans spectacle opening
ceremonies are not like it's it's about
that competition in those games so i
think that's what we're
we're most excited for other sports
making their debuts
karate surfing and skateboarding
sports that have massive followings and
established communities
yet are only now making their olympic
debuts it really doesn't hit until you
stop
and think about it like every once in a
while i'll sit down with someone and
i'll talk about it
wow that is insane that this is the
first time
ever this is going to be included in the
olympics all the new sport athletes say
they've thought about how they'll
represent their disciplines to the world
they want an audience and medals too of
course
as far as the crowd goes i'm i i could
say i'm fairly bummed
but it's not it's not like i'm going to
the olympics bro that
it's hard to find a downside in that
totally bro
mike drew like global news toronto
luck out there bro and that is global
national for this saturday night
i'm jeff semple tonight your canada is
peterborough ontario
we would love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending us those
photos
to viewers at globalnational.com thank
you for watching and i'll be back here
with you tomorrow
have a great night
you